[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
mein name ist thomas sarbacher ich bin
schauspieler wenn sie den literaturclub
im schweizer fernsehen sehen dann haben
sie mich da auch schon lesen gehört und
ich stehe jetzt hier in bern vor dem
kunstmuseum und habe eine verabredung
mit der direktorin des hauses frau nina
zimmer ich habe das große privileg als
einziger besucher ihres museums heute
durch die hallen zu schleichen mich an
den kunstwerken zu ergötzen und mir vor
allem meine ganzen fragen beantworten zu
lassen und sie dürfen gleich mein name
ist nina zimmer ich bin die direktorin
vom kunstmuseum bern und vom zentrum
paul klee
es ist himmeltraurig dass wir die museen
schließen mussten aber heute habe ich
große freude dass ich ein gast empfangen
darf dass der thomas sarbacher freue
mich schon extrem freue mich dass sie da
sind und ich freue mich dass sie sich
zeit genommen
hinein ins schöne museum dankeschön so
dass wir immer diesen abstand hier
[Musik]
danke naja des handspiels kurz abhängen
man kann sagen einer der international
berühmtesten gegenwartskünstler der auf
großen biennale venedig großen
überblicksausstellung zu sehen war
man konnte ihn an vielen berühmten
museen der welt sehen andererseits ist
es auch eine besonderheit weil er ein
künstler aus afrika ist ursprünglich aus
ghana einer der wenigen die auch weiter
in afrika leben erlebt seit vielen
jahren in nigeria und hat generationen
von künstlern auch weiter mit
ausgebildet hat eine große nachfolge ist
deswegen sowohl als lehrer mensch aber
auch durch seine überragenden erfolg als
künstler international eine absolute
ausnahme figur
[Musik]
es ist ja erst mal überwältigend weil es
weil es also natürlich auch durch die
strich durch die größe die wort die das
entwickelt und und ganz also das hat man
ja immer bei betrachtung von kunstwerken
diese differenz oder den unterschied
wenn man nach angeht
und wenn man weiter weg geht und hier
ist es natürlich noch mal nochmal
extremer weil die weil die welt die
bearbeitung dieser kleinen dieser
kleinen elemente so unterschiedlichen so
vielgestaltig ist kann man sich
sozusagen so im einzelnen verlieren hat
sich hierdurch die durch die durch das
glitzernde zwischen ist ungeheuer
erhabenes und dann und dagegen steht
dann so dieses freche bunte das ja das
schöne beobachtung die würde ich gern
grad aufnehmen diese das glitzernde
wertvolle erhabene glaube das ist was
was man ziemlich schnell spült ich stehe
vor was ganz besondere und dieser glanz
wo wird natürlich auch bemüht haben in
der beleuchtung dass nach der reise
reflexionen gibt der der soll auch
dieses kostbare betonen man sieht ja
auch die vielen elemente dass auch viele
einzelne arbeit die dahinter steckt dass
er auch eine werte es ist das ist was
wichtiges die arbeit also wenn man sieht
hier vorne diese
die sind ja die sind ja speziell dafür
gefragt worden
also gebt gefaltet zusammengedrückt und
das ist ja ein immenses ein immenser
arbeitsaufwand lassen was natürlich dass
er eben was sehr wertvoll es ist ja per
se genau und dann guckt man genauer und
dann dieses wertvolle jahr weil man
sieht aber das sind einfach nur so alle
schraubverschlüssen von getränken und
ich glaube das haben wir alle schon mal
gemacht dass man im lauf des lehrens
einer solchen flasche anfängt zu spielen
mit dem schraubverschluss mit dem alu es
den es gibt
und aus diesen spielen falten drücken
mit der hand umgehen mit dem material
hat dazu mit diesen völlig anderen
umgang entwickelt der bis in diesem
moment steht dann geht und da ist dieser
die dass dieser kitt moment vom vom
wertvollen ins wertlose dergleichen
spannender moment
[Musik]
das ist ja flexibel und das ist ja auch
so ein wesentlicher punkt bei ihnen ist
es auch veränderbar bleibt aber die wie
zufällig ist es die die hänge also weil
er war jetzt auch nicht darum das selber
zu überwachen oder war ja leider
tatsächlich wegen der aktuellen
situation konnte er nicht mehr reisen
wir haben mit seinen langjährigen
studienleitern zusammengearbeitet und
mit zwei kuratoren also dem kurator
chicago der die ausstellung mit
entwickelt und initiiert hatte und
catherine bühler hier bei uns im haus
die die räume kennt und was wir gelernt
haben wir haben am anfang gedacht unsere
aufgabe ist die besten reproduktions
fotos und so wie wir die arbeiten auch
im haus der kunst in münchen gesehen
hatten dass wir genau dieselben wellen
und faltungen wieder her bringen müssen
also wir hatten uns bemüht uns ganz
genau die die ein zu denken wie schaffen
wir das das war so eine welle und da so
im verlauf gibt 1 der allererste
erkenntnisse war das wird bei jeder
aufführung sag ich jetzt mal des werkes
wieder neu geformt also diese werke
haben keine definitiven das ist die
chance zu sagen man kann sogar die
analogie weitertreiben sagen der stoff
ist ja genau
[Musik]
m
er entwickelt mit seinem team er hat ein
großes team was im atelier unterstützt
er arbeitet ja im kontext von der
kunstakademie in nigeria
das heißt da gibt es sehr viele künstler
die ihn unterstützen in bei dieser sehr
stark arbeitsteiligen vorgehensweise und
die fangen an mit kleinen stücken und
zeigen ihm was die sozusagen
zusammengestellt haben
und manchmal physisch legt er das auf
dem boden zusammen und dann schieben sie
elemente hin und her dass das dauert zum
teil lange bis er das dann arrangiert
hat bis es zum werk erklärt aber dann
bleibt quasi von der werk form offen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
darüber ein bisschen was gelesen also
klar wir reden hier jetzt auch von
diesen von diesen traum verschlüssen von
von schnapsflaschen und und eine teil 1
teil dieser aussage der der aussage
seines werks ja die dass er sagt die
sklaven wurden in die neue welt
verschifft um dazu gar ort zu bauen dazu
wurde nach europa transportiert da wurde
der schnaps produziert und mit dem man
die sklavenhändler dann ihren handel
betrieben so plötzlich hat das plötzlich
hat es eine geschlossene oder
geschlossen aber eine klare aussage und
er und die kriegt etwas ungeheuer
kraftvoll ist ein starkes nach seiner
tatsächlichen blick also zumindest in
ausstand einen blick auf die welt wirft
und sagt so funktioniert das und ich
überlege also wo ich mich frage also
führt ihnen das material an an dieser
aussage oder also wie rum wo ist die
händler und wo ist das also sozusagen in
der erfindung haben sie da haben sie da
jetzt als kunsthistorikerin zugang dazu
oder oder ist das nimmt man das wir
gehen da sind sie so ein bisschen beim
mythischen kern geheimnis einer
künstlerischen produktion
das ist sehr unterschiedlich wie einem
künstlerinnen und künstler einblick
gewähren in diese in dieses
allerheiligste dieser entstehung von
formen und sind produktion
ich glaube so weit ich mich dem werk von
ella nazi angenähert habe dass es bei
ihm hand in hand geht
das ist jetzt ein reifes werk das auch
die jüngsten arbeiten die wir von ihm
zeigen wo er auf diesen wirklich
kontinent umspannenden dreiecks handel
sie haben es gesagt mit dem hintergrund
der kolonialen ausbeutung und
des verbrecherischen sklavenhandels dass
er darauf rekurriert aber das war
sozusagen nicht in sein
ab der ersten arbeit schon programm
sondern seine arbeitsweise hat eine
offenheit das ist glaube ich das
ungeheuer zeitgenössische an dieser
arbeit dass er nicht bestimmte
historische umstände illustriert sondern
dass er sehr zeitgenössische
künstlerische herangehensweise gefunden
hat die diese themen mitnimmt aber auch
neue formen schafft dabei
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt in der ausstellung von
terror yoko der rokoko ist eine berner
künstlerin lebt seit 60 jahren in bern
und gleichzeitig eine absolut
internationale künstlerin von ihrer
karriere her
sie ist geboren in japan noch zur
kaiserzeit mit einem amerikanischen
schiff gleich nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
nach kalifornien gegangen ist dort kunst
studiert hat dann nach new york gegangen
ist dort war sie in der heißesten
internationalen kunstszene der
abstrakten amerikanischen
expressionisten sie hat mark roskow
kennengelernt aber auch sam francis den
sie später geheiratet hat sie war teil
der gruppe und irgendwo doch auch am
rande der gruppe sie blieb auch
japanerin in amerika
[Applaus]
also hier kann man eigentlich ein werk
des amerikanischen abstrakten
expressionismus ist frisch gemalt und
mit dieser quasi abschätzig kite von
handwerklicher perfektion man hat so
nicht mal trocknen gelassen sondern man
läßt du so richtig laufen
das ist diese sehr rotzige aggressive
new yorker geste von wir zeigen den
malprozess wieder so richtig aus der
tube kommt das gehört eigentlich in den
kammern abstrakter amerikanischer
malerei sowie es da ist es wunderbar das
ist jetzt genau das stichwort was ich
brauche wenn ich vor einem abstrakten
bild steht dann hab ich manchmal das
gefühl schließlich ins dorf gibt es
etwas wo sie sagen also das was
sozusagen wie jetzt die attraktion
liefern soll nämlich eine übersetzung
dessen was als bildet sozusagen dahinter
liegt gibt es etwas an dem man sich
daran festhalten kann
sie sind nicht zu doof es geht aber auch
gar nicht ums schlau sein vorbild es
geht darum ob man dialog hinbekommt mit
einem bild oder nicht
und bei den guten bildern gelingt einem
das und viele bilder werden für immer
einen verschlossen bleiben aber es gibt
nicht den einen schlüssel dass man sagt
eigentlich ist es zwar abstrakt aber in
wirklichkeit sind lauter blumen
dargestellt man muss nur ein bisschen
mehr zwinkern oder so man muss es rück
übersetzen in eine zeit innen kontext
was bedeutet es in einer bestimmten zeit
in einem umfeld ohne gegenstand zu malen
und ohne malerei die transportiert
aggression die transportiert
körperlichkeit in dem das format so groß
ist es geht um auch eine sehr
jugendliche wilde aufruhr gegen die
schöne klassische malerei
[Musik]
da ist in francis hier das ist die
hochzeit ist er im frances schneidet die
torte und sie gelächelt ihn wirklich
voller liebe an
sie arbeitet direkt auf dem boden direkt
auf die leinwände
das ist ein tolles bild mittmann ihren
ganzen raten wer die kuratoren zu sam
francis ins atelier kommen und nur nach
san francisco argen und er sich auch
nicht bemüht zu sagen oh meine frau ist
übrigens künstlerin ist arnold
rücklinger der schweizer kurator zu
besuch im atelier new york und er sagt
von wem sind in diese gemälde da und
dann sagt er das war meine frau trug und
am nördlinger lädt sie ein für eine
ausstellung in basel
ja und wie war das verhältnis als sam
francis gemerkt hat dass es jetzt um
seine frau geht wissen sie das schwierig
schwierig also die er hat ja auch nicht
wirklich lange gehalten also das ist
eine generation männer die natürlich da
auch mühe hatten mit einer doppelten
karriere das aus zu hause und es gab
natürlich viele faktoren die es auch
nicht einfach gewirkt haben
[Musik]
theo koll lebt weiter in bern lebt in
sie ist jetzt über 90 lebt in einer
betreuten einrichtung und wir dürfen sie
im moment nicht mehr besuchen und sie
darf auch im moment uns nicht mehr sehen
das sind die aktuellen umstände wir
haben ihre öffnung noch feiern können
zusammen mit ihrer tochter den ganzen
familie
ich denke in großer dankbarkeit zurück
dass wir das so gross noch feiern
durften und dass sie selbst auch teil
von diesem moment sein konnte
wunderschön
[Musik]
also wenn solche ausstellungen
vorzubereiten
ist es denn mal realisiert ist es hat ja
im vorlauf und was bedeutet das für sie
jetzt emotional sozusagen das nach außen
gebracht zu haben endlich
und jetzt ist schicht im schacht also
kein mensch kann sehen wie wie ist es so
in dem gefühlshaushalt das nimmt also
die ganze lebensgrundlage uns gibt es ja
nur fürs publikum und in der
auseinandersetzung mit dem publikum und
auf einmal gehen die türen zu also das
ding ist man weiß ja und man hört die
nachrichten um man weiß es geht anderen
viel viel schlimmer oder es geht um viel
größeres als um ein kleines kunstmuseum
deswegen ist man ja auch schnell wieder
weg von seinen eigenen gefühlen dabei
und selbstverständlich sind alle
programme die wir geplant haben für nach
der wiedereröffnung und da geht ihre
frage ja auch ein bisschen hin
wir werden in einer anderen welt wieder
öffnen und wir denken natürlich jetzt
diese ganzen projekte die nachher kommen
auch noch mal ganz anders also was im
herbst eröffnet ist eine ausstellung
über tools for you tube ja über die neue
gesellschaft aus der
lateinamerikanischen revolutionären
kunst heraus gedacht und die hat auf
einmal natürlich einen ganz anderen
nachklang der ausstellung kann sie denn
jetzt die chance jeden morgen erst mal
kurz durch zu gehen und sich an den
bildern zu freuen bevor sie dann an ihre
arbeit gehen oder kommen sie dazu gar
nicht dass wir schön aber zum einen
haben wir gar kein licht an wir haben
alle räume eigentlich dunkel damit auch
die werke geschützt sind für die zeit
ist es alles unter hoher sicherheit ich
bräuchte ein ganzes team um überhaupt
hochzufahren die ausstellungen
das können wir im moment nicht machen
das haben wir für sie gemacht heute ich
bin sehr dankbar und auch für das
basilan bereit ist
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos